[Music]
I've just given you such a punch imagine
a better person to talk to it this time
about how to plummet the depths of our
creative minds as an entrepreneur when
you are one of the leading authorities
when it comes to that I mean your your
video that you did that's a few in 2016
they had 30 million hits on 90 seconds
in the life of lifetime of a what was it
90 seconds lifetime lives and you've
taken adversity and turned adversity
into something that is something very
powerful you really understand
entrepreneurship so I couldn't think of
a better person to to talk to so thank
you for joining me today
kiss this is coffee with Caroline it's
so good and we just recently always lost
yes she doesn't recently I did that
interview with you and it was it was so
powerful you have I've been interviewed
by a lot of people but boy was your
interview one of my favorite because you
you made me think about my work
you made me think so critically and dig
so deep inside myself and that's what I
love about you you you really dig into
people's heads and you make us question
everything and that is phenomenal so
tell my people about who you are and and
a lot of people obviously know you and
just how can you help us in this crazy
time way covert and racism and awareness
and a new global thinking has changed
the way that we function yeah so my
background born and raised in Iran lived
there for ten years you know in Iran if
you are Christian you are taught not to
tell people what you are your parents
will tell you if anybody ever asked you
if you're a Christian don't tell him so
near on we were Armenian a Syrian family
and my parents are Christian so
eventually we escaped in Ramallah to
Germany had a refugee camp lived there
for two years and it came out here lived
here six years and I joined the army
went to the hunter first airborne got
out I got into business specifically in
financial services with Morgan Stanley
Dean Witter became a broker day before
9/11 and I went to trans America for
seven and a half years and then after
that started
company October of oh nine with
sixty-six agents and now we have over
15,000 agents nationwide and we're in 49
different states on hundred thirty
offices but currently I work we got a
bunch of people working in the back this
is just support one side of the office
but and then you know value tainment
that grew to the channel that it is
today with a few million subs you know I
will tell you this for me I was given a
talk for a commencement speed for this
school and they asked me to give him a
message and they said so you know what
do you think about what's going on right
now and how should we process this I
said look if high school is the biggest
high of your life in a way you failed
life because high school cannot be the
biggest high of your life high school is
the phase of your life and you grow you
it's okay to reminisce it's okay to go
back and say yeah it's okay to go back
and say you know what you know here's
what I did in high school I enjoyed this
we did this I played sports my best
friends were there we used to be part of
this group used to be part of a group we
score two parties we used to go to
dances I used to date this girl I used
to date that guy it's fine
but to me almost everything that helped
me become Who I am today
it was a byproduct of a tough time I
don't know why everything that helped me
become Who I am today is a byproduct of
tough times we have agents all over the
country that we bring on board and we
recruit and we built and I can tell you
the top producers have either had a
sports background they were either in
military or they were in some kind of an
environment where there was a lot of
pressure and it could handle the
pressure and then they eventually use it
in business to do well for themselves so
there's almost a requirement to have
some experience of going through tough
times now during times like this you can
have three different types of people
just like any time it's gonna produce
the three different types of people
those that will be to pay setters on how
they come out of kovat and how they come
out setting an example for everybody
else then you'll have the responders
responders will be those who wait for
the pacesetters to make the move and
then they'll respond to what the
pacesetter does
and then you'll have the late bloomers
unfortunately the late bloomers will
take a hit like they always do in every
single thing that happens in life the
responders are going to be fine and the
pace setters are either gonna be
criticized or they're gonna be seen as
heroes it's a lot of risk and being a
year pace setter so you got to make a
decision which one you're gonna be one
of the things I wouldn't be is I
wouldn't be coming out the gate slow if
if I'm out I'd be figuring out a way how
to position myself on a marketplace
today mmm that's brilliant that's there
is very carful you can be one of three
and what you're advising is get a hit so
how do you do it what would you give
some could you interviewed some of the
most amazing people and as you've saved
collectively and this is not something
that's this is fairly common knowledge
if people are going to really make a
change they've come through adversity
and I know from my brain scientific
research as well it changes how your
brain functions a different level of
intelligence and because intelligence is
something that we we grow ourselves so
that's not something that's fixed it's
something they could keep growing and
and a deep it in Taine's critical
thinking and the entrepreneurial spirit
that drives you forward taking their
diversity energy and kennen living in
the right direction that's what I'm
hearing you say how do you do that
you've got your background is you've
just outlined very quickly and we've got
a podcast coming up soon we're going to
really dive into that any more tapes and
this is a limited time but what can you
tell people too how can you meet the
pace later or the responder versus the
person who hangs around and wait I think
I think the one question you know I have
a book coming out I don't copy negative
to promote a book you probably should
have a copy next so don't have an answer
but I have a book coming I called your
next five months and and the first thing
that I talk about with anybody I work
with it's by far the most important
question I answered your next five years
is coming out with Simon & Schuster it's
coming out August 18th one person wants
to if a person wants to get a chapter of
it if they go to your next five moves
calm and you'll see how to get a chapter
but you read it but the most important
question I think people have to answer
doc is you know you have to make a
decision in a marketplace on who you
want to be and here's what I mean by who
you want to be I've seen so many people
frustrated
upset you know they'll say something
like well look at the other person but
they're doing better than me but look at
the other person they're doing better
than me but look at that person right
there
and look at this person right here and
it creates bitterness Envy and I'll
always bring them back and I'll say
listen why don't you stop looking at
everybody and ask yourself who you want
to be in your family who you want to be
in the community who you want to be in
the world what do you mean by that
you would be amazed how many people
don't have the answer to the question of
who you want to be so let me unpack that
a little bit what do you mean by who do
you want to be okay I once had a guy who
I hired he became the president of my
company one of the most important hires
ever made in the company we're friends
still today we've been friends for 12
years and he told me something powerful
I call him Wikipedia because you can ask
him anything he has an answer for it is
that was a rocket scientist he sold the
company for six hundred and eighty
million dollars jammed a cool EA Sports
and he was the number seven guy in that
company he's still got a massive a multi
seven-figure check then he went and was
part of Sony then he started his own few
companies he failed the companies he
started the most money he ever made was
as number seven percent and he sent me
nine says Pat I gotta take this I said
what's that he says I'm not a good
number one I said where are you going
with this
he says I'm a very good number two three
four five but I'm not a good number one
I said how do you say that like that
doesn't hurt your ego it's just no I
just know I'm not a good number one you
realize how hard that is for a person to
say that but he realized I make my money
as a five I succeed as a six I don't
succeed as a one there's this idea where
everybody wants to be loved my gosh look
at Michael Jordan you know he's the
number one Scottie Pippen didn't do well
as a number one he did good as a number
two you got certain people don't want to
become presidents they don't make good
president
you know like ulysses s grant was a
terrible president he didn't like being
a president he was an incredible general
you know so but you've got certain
presidents that if you put him in
military that would make terrible
generals but they make good presidents a
very weird dynamic you know do you want
to be an Operations person do you want
to be a CEO do you want to be an
entrepreneur do you want to be an int
preneur do you want to be a solopreneur
how big do you want to build it do you
want to be the person the family that
everybody relies on and they go to for
counsel advised you're the example
people want to be like you well you're
the example that comes with a lot of
pressure do you really want that
pressure being a role model maybe you
don't if you just kind of want to be on
the sidelines and no one's bothering you
and you just live a very calm life and
you don't want to be judged and you
don't want to get into wrinkles you're
gonna get a black eye what if you lose
and if you lose people gonna laugh at
you simulating I don't want that kind of
pressure and then that's one question so
now here's the second part of that
question for people to start in a time
like this the second part of that
question is say you just said who you
want to be how much of what you said um
who you want to be has to do with you
minimizing exposure versus wanting to
seek your capacity because that's the
moment for example so somebody says well
you know I really don't want all that
pressure be I just want to be a regular
person okay fair say you want to do that
let's just say you're 74 years old and
you chose to play safe life are you
gonna be okay being 74 years old looking
back saying I wish I would have done
more because I'm so disappointed with my
life because that's also not the right
decision to make so you can also take
the safe life because if you take the
safe life then you're gonna live with
regrets later on so you gotta balance
those two out to ask yourself who do you
want to be and then at the same time are
you okay if you live a life never
reaching your full potential if the
answer is yes don't forget about it just
go do whatever you want to do and live a
simple life but if there's a part of you
that you're sitting on and saying you
know what I don't know man I just you
know these are weird times you know I've
had friends that I lost and you know all
the one minute everybody's telling you
to stay home the next minute the
politicians are telling you go protest
I'm confused
do they even know what their one-minute
the doctors are saying that you should
put a mask on next minute they're saying
masks don't work next minute as people
are getting arrested I don't know what's
going on this is so confusing I see
myself as a Democrat but then I relate
to Republicans I see myself as a
Republican but I relate to Democrats I'm
confused I don't even know what I am
today politically I thought I like this
guy I don't like this guy I thought I
didn't like this guy now I like this guy
this is confusing
this is by far Caroline by far by far
the best time for somebody to sit down
and ask themselves the important
questions that they haven't asked for a
while and that getting to study the most
important product with which is yourself
because once you do that then it's about
your next 5 10 15 moves once you know
who you want to be coming up with the
next 5 10 15 moves that's gonna be hard
but right now the most important pivotal
thing I'd be doing this who do you want
to be in your family who do you want to
be in a marketplace how you want to be
compensated how big of a life do you
want to live based on diet go solve for
X and come up with your next 10 15 steps
to go become that person that you want
to be that's what I'd be doing if I'd
found them and you know we positioned
for the first time in history he said
that for the first seven history all of
humanity are facing the same in me so
globally me facing the same enemy which
is this unknown covert and overnight the
world Keynes and overnight things
changed overnight we collectively
started being forced to think
differently about what we've been doing
for the last 30 years and how we got
here and yes it's been done in very
different ways but it has forced us to
as you say think we are in ideal
position now to go back to almost core
basic route which is do you think very
deeply about the questions that you've
seen between eat for the last 30 years
with this modern era be being so busy
being busy that we forgotten all about
thinking and there's so much scientific
research showing that and we see the
impact in the brain we even see me maybe
look at moment of data bases how they've
changed in the last 20 years because
people have changed
they don't think deeply and I think even
what it's changed its had a negative
impact and that so this is almost like a
bringing to sort of really sore knees
moment where we can think deeply we've
got to use as energy so effectively so
that question that you posed is what do
you want what do you want for your
brilliant because it's basic stuff it
starts with identity from once you once
you know who you are you can then start
sticking out into making those changes
whatever they look like and I also love
what you said about people are spending
so much time saying look what they've
got and then gave us an English which
causes brain damage just by the way
and then you're wasting that energy
which is limited in us on toxic stuff
instead of turning them into wow that's
amazing
how phenomenal which boosts your energy
in your brain and now boost your
creativity and now you can instead of
being jealous you can actually go and
say okay so what can I do I'm hearing
you say that and I'm hearing you say
channel that energy in the right
direction because on top of this just
prove it we've now got this race as an
issue which is now very much in our
awareness and it's so good because you
did some of the research I did over the
years was looking at changes and on in
organizations whether it's a school a
church a company and individual and
there's a general train people want to
change and things like a little blip
people changing and they kind of go back
and then and they stay and I'm saying
that's true relate to what you were
saying that you can be one of those
people that says what I can I want to
change but I don't think I'm going to
bring the Isetta I wanted and then you
just kind of stay flat learn and it's 74
you look back and say my life was a
bunch of blips with flat lines but when
you deliberate and intentional this is
what I showed in my research you can
change as an individual and as an
organization and as a country and as a
society you can change 35 to 75 percent
immediately by just changing how you
your mind sakes change it just being to
look at any tensional and I think this
is what I think this is what I know you
have done as an individual with every
circumstances so what do you how do you
kind of translate that kind of into
practical terms yeah again I think we
spend way too much time with things we
have zero control over and it's so
draining you know I like to come with
the news I like to watch the news but
the last couple weeks I just don't even
want to watch it I read it I don't even
want to watch I read the news I don't
watch the news right now because it's
too much it's it's too much of stuff
that you have zero control of and you
put too much energy into that look you
start off in the morning when you're in
the morning you have a cup of energy
right and your energy has got only this
much energy the more you allow other
things to suck that energy then by
middle of the day the world's getting
the worst of your energy whatever's left
versus I'm gonna conserve my energy and
I'm gonna give the best of my energy to
the areas that
my highest return and unfortunately
that's not what a lot of people are
doing today you got it you know
business-wise let me let me talk a
little bit about dreams so here's a guy
he gets out of high school parents get a
divorce twice on two years among my
sisters two years old my parents get a
divorce the first time then they come
back and everybody pressures them cuz in
Iran you're not supposed to get divorced
and it's not a good thing they get
remarried and with the idea of let us
have a second kid hopefully the second
kid's gonna make the marriage work
I'm born okay after I'm born few years
later they get a divorce so my parents
get a divorce
twice in 20 years okay so we come to the
States
I'm a regular to Kona high school 1.8
GPA I am told by the recruiter in my
counts or look you know you're not this
regular life is not worth to you you
stop it's not something you can compete
in your big guy your six-four six-five
you have muscles join the army so I go
into the army Army's gonna give you
great benefits go into that life you get
college you get all this other stuff you
get a nice GI Bill try going to the army
I listen to them no problem they said
I'm not the smartest guy I don't have
the biggest great armies for me I went
there right then eventually got to a
point where I'm like sitting there
questioning everything I'm like wait a
minute why not you know why well yeah I
remember I was a kid I asked my mom an
interesting question this is gonna be a
little bit crazy for some of you guys
when I say this to you because you know
you may take in a different way I said
mom what are we you know in school
they're Tomic Democrats and Republicans
what are we mom and my mom said oh you
know we're Democrats because Democrats
are for the poor and Republicans are for
the rich I told my mom I said you know
what I'd love to be a Republican one
Democrat a Republican I'd love to be
rich one thing so what I'm trying to say
I'd left our money one day I'm not
trying to say I'd love to be a
Republican one day yeah all these are
the things that come with it it's very
simple I'd like to have some money one
day why here's what I like to have some
money one day there is nothing more
annoying than family members and
relatives around your classmates around
you kind of looking down at you like
you know you know oh poor Patrick you
know it comes from a broken thumb that
don't feel sorry for me I don't want you
to feel bad for me and people would come
and give us gifts on Thanksgiving and
like that kind of stuff I never liked it
I don't want gifts of feel sorry gifts
give me a good gift cuz you want to give
me a gift don't give me a gift cause you
feel sorry for my family Alice I don't
want I don't want any feeling sorry type
of stuff because the more and more you
accept that psychologically you believe
you are sorry you accept I'm not
accepting are you making that judgment
yourself I'm not buying that so this is
what I would say to the people that are
watching this three times for me massive
crisis has happened the last 20 years so
watch this each time it's made me a
fortune first one was you know when 9/11
took place when 9/11 happened I got
started into the financial industry day
before 9/11 okay
910 is on Monday I'm at Morgan Stanley
Glendale everything is fire I'm about to
go to New York World Trade Center
because that's where Morgan Stanley's
headquarters was 3,600 employees worked
at the World Trade Center I'm excited
I'm gonna go to New York next day I come
to work 5:30 6:30 in the morning we're
having a manager's meeting the guy in
the corner starts screamin turn on the
monitor turn on the monitor all the
employees Dave Kirby my manager what's
going on we turn on the monitor boom we
saw the first plane then we saw the
second plane flew into Morgan Stanley's
headquarters so imagine you're working
at IBM and the IBM headquarters gets
shot up I mean you're supposed to go to
that headquarters my boss Dave Kirby
says everybody go home everybody who
were on the ninth floor in Glendale we
all go home okay now you know everybody
remembers where they were out on 9/11
when it has yeah so I go home on like oh
my gosh what just happened today the
next day I go to work
Carolyne everybody was afraid your
brokers yeah they were afraid they were
concerned they don't want to pick up the
call Dave kept saying pick up the calls
guys call your clients no no call your
clients call your client they lose the
money but call your clients people are
afraid okay
he sat us down and he says hey new
brokers I want to say something to you
guys we're like what's that I highly
recommend you guys leave the industry
because this industry is gonna be very
hard the next three years he says but if
you're crazy enough to stick around it's
gonna be very good
years from now i sat there one guy named
shaq asian guy he came up and he says
hey pat i'm going to bank they're
offering me a nice position i salary and
you get to use their clients because
when you're working for a bank it's a
lot easier to be an adviser because
you're just flipping the checking
account saving accounts into new --'tis
which ones all this other stuff he says
we should go to the bank I was so
tempted I said now I'm not going he says
you're gonna stick around I says listen
it's a bad time as I'm sticking around
so I stuck around first crisis 911 made
me a million dollars okay watch the
second crisis second crisis was 2008
when the market tanked 38% in a year
okay 2008 market tanked 38% a year I
started my insurance company a year
later the second crisis made me you know
couple hundred million dollars the
following decade okay
I'm 41 right now today cope it happens
I'm in LA March 12th for our board
meeting a meeting with De La Hoya and
all these guys and all my board Mina
guys are traveling from Connecticut
Greenwich and they're coming from New
York and while we land in LA at Beverly
Hills Hilton I take my three kids
because we love Universal Studios and I
take my wife on my three kids in our
nanny and we're there and we're like
listen I'm gonna have the board meeting
but let's protect the kids to Universal
for the day no problem I'll and in the
news hits NHL shutting down MBA shutting
down Adam Silver shutting down you know
Disney World shutting down you know no
one's going to these parks and then all
of a sudden the news my main guys are my
board I'm not coming from Greenwich why
not I don't want to you coronavirus then
my other guy from New York I'm not
coming former president Hartford like oh
my gosh everybody's canceling then I
start getting text messages from
everybody that's afraid in the company
what are we gonna do how are we gonna
handle this I'm like okay this is not a
time to go to Universal I say babe we're
getting on the plane we're going back to
Dallas so we get on a plane we come back
to Dallas it's gonna be very interesting
data I'm about to share with everybody
we come back to Dallas I'm in LA for
less than 24 hours we come to Dallas we
land I take my wife and kids home and my
nanny home they go home I said babe
you're not gonna see me for some time
she says what do you mean I said I got
to go figure out what the hell is going
on so I come straight to the
this I'm right here okay you've been in
this office before yeah my office I lock
up everything I tell everybody to go
home
I sit by myself for 14 hours all I do is
research myself on what the last 10
pandemics did and what the consequences
were six twelve months later now watch
this
I go look at the pandemics last ten more
SARS AIDS everyone what I made a video
about it all of them so here's what data
came up very crazy data this is where my
confidence came that everything's going
to be all right data came back up that
out of the last ten pandemics that we've
experienced I'm not talking like 1800s
or 60s I'm talking about from 1920 till
today last 10 pandemics yeah
9 out of 10 times the economy recovered
six months later how crazy is that the
only one six months later the economy
went back to exactly what it was the
debut before the pandemic was announced
right six months later the only pandemic
that the economy was still down 12
months later was aids aids was the only
one everything else recovered so now
watch this so I'm sitting there looking
at the same there is a 90% chance that
the economy is gonna recover in six
months meaning everybody all my friends
all I took my money out of equities or I
took my money out of equities mistake
mistake mistake no do it mistake stay
tight said 90 percent no no no you don't
understand this is time you got to take
it out I have one of my guys that works
for me that they've been on the market
for a long time they were there working
on ten million they took their money out
and they just went back into the market
too late they lost three million dollars
in market out okay so I stay put I told
everybody around me I'm not telling you
what to do here's what I'm doing with my
money this is what I'm buying great then
I took that confidence on what we need
to do I looked at what we needed to do
employee wise I send 80% of my employees
so um I had a meeting with everybody and
I said guys tell me any questions you
have about pandemic ask me any questions
what your concerns are
I'm pregnant I don't want to work from
home you're gonna be working from home
on this my wife is a nurse she's having
to go to work because the corona bar
we have a kid and they send us from all
they can't go to school what do we do
you work from home what a like so we
address every issue right okay here's
our position when we made that move and
I came back Caroline we were doing four
to five thousand policies per month in
january/february this last month in a
month of May we did ten thousand 968
insurance policies in a month our record
high was six thousand 664 we've never
done 11,000 policies in a month shy up
never we are our biggest top-line
revenue biggest emitter biggest every
growth profit everything why though
after doing a ton of research it gave me
confidence that there's a 90% chance
everything's gonna be alright
then we moved unfortunately too often
our research is only CNN Fox MSNBC and
what people post on Instagram and
Facebook that's our news and I think
that's a big problem because we are
allowing things we have no control over
to make us feel the way we do so once I
got into that state of confidence I
immediately held the zoom three times a
week with every single one of my VP's we
typically only do one Zuma month with
our VPS
we did three a week I got them all out
to see what they look like I don't want
to do a conference call I said there's
one I want to see her face and I could
see they were defeated
half of them were defeated and I'm like
okay that guy's defeated she always wore
makeup I've never seen her without
makeup on she barely has any makeup on
that guy looks scared and we went on a
two and a half hours oom I said what's
on your mind I said hey take a look at
this take a look at this take a look at
this here's what we can do we can be
afraid or we can play offense and do our
best what do you guys want to do and I'm
okay if you guys want to sit on the
sidelines and be afraid this is what
your seal is gonna be doing since March
12 till today I missed four days of work
I've been at the office every day even
though I'm a non-essential business and
I'm not supposed to be now some people
may say you broke the rules for days
I've missed every since for Sunday's I
miss I was here I got closer to my kids
the last 12 weeks then I've ever been
because they were at the office every
day with me we got a lot of stuff done
so when somebody's watching this right
now st. Pat what do you think about what
I should be doing
giving energy to things you have zero
control over and put energy and conserve
it it into things that's gonna give you
high return were your dreams become a
reality
yours your husband's your wives your
kids the people around you so when you
wake up and you look at yourself in the
mirror you say you know what I'm proud
of you I like the way you leave that be
my biggest suggestion to people today
everyone this is why Patrick is one of
my favorite people one of the most
motivating people but not just
motivating I hate a shirt that would one
of the most inspiring but you realist
you've given practical examples you've
shown us how to plant deep and I
recommend that you if you haven't
watched any of that you tamen you need
to watch it because this is how you can
really find out who you are as a person
take it Clement is that you I want to
thank you for what you signal is
outstanding I cannot wait to do a
podcast where we can dive even deeper
and people can have a lot more time to
listen to what you've got to say just to
support what you see there how use it
we've got limited energy don't use it on
finding we getting a research from the
media do your research in the proper way
would you did they put it 14 hours and
then you'd actually made a video so
people can go to that you tainment and
they can see that video on the fact that
within six months in 90% of the cases
the economy was there contract you we've
got the evidence they but you did
hardcore research and this is what what
to control you took control you didn't
just leave yourself get budgeted by the
winds of what was going on you took
control you drove your energy and you
have succeeded and that is incredibly
good advice for every single one of us
I've just finished a set of clinical
trials that are in over last June one of
the many things I looked at and one of
the things was that when you when a
person starts getting autonomy which is
the sense of control and awareness
changes inside of us and suddenly the
toxic thoughts of getting all worked up
etc or whatever but the whole range of
toxic thoughts is huge which then causes
toxic stress those will go down so with
autonomy comes awareness comes a control
of toxic thoughts and toxic stress leads
to empowerment and well-being it's
literally a pathway to empowerment so
scientifically I just been showing what
you've just described
answer in such a phenomenal way so thank
you I'm so excited to have bought you on
today and thank you for your wisdom and
people listen to this 100 times gave
Patrick's box watch human value tainment
and watch out for a podcast and go check
out my podcast interview with Patrick
pulled stuff out of me that I didn't
even know was there